mes chers amis je voudrais commencer par
vous faire une confidence
certains d'entre vous me sifflent
certains ça me fait de la peine
mais ça ne change pas ma détermination
vous êtes ma famille je resterai dans ma
famille et mon action politique se
déroulera toujours dans ma famille pour
moi est sans doute pour beaucoup d'entre
vous le moment que nous vivons est
chargée d'émotion je repense à la belle
journée du 17 novembre 2002 ou
gaullistes libéraux démocrates chrétiens
se sont unis pour donner le coup d'envoi
à notre ump il avait fallu deux grands
efforts pour surmonter les divisions du
passé il y avait fallu le soutien sans
faille de jacques chirac à qui j'adresse
comme beaucoup d'entre vous j'en suis
sûr mais affectueuse français il y avait
fallu l'engagement de tous nos
fondateurs l'union nous a conduit à de
belles victoires
nous avons aussi connu des échecs
douloureux
c'est le lot de toute aventure politique
mais l'ambition du rassemblement était
la bonne
elle reste plus nécessaire que jamais
maintenant allons de l'avant
le temps n'est pas à la nostalgie je me
réjouis de partager avec vous l'
enthousiasme d'un nouveau départ celui
des républicains à qui je souhaite de
tout coeur bon vent pas trois mouvements
peut compter sur mon concours
ma loyauté mon ardeur j'ai aimé l'ump et
j'aimerais les républicains une lourde
responsabilité pèse sur nos épaules
celle de remettre la france sur le bon
chemin
en rassemblant les français autour d'un
projet qui leur donne confiance
confiance à domène confiance dans notre
destin commun pour réussir
commençons par ne pas nous tromper
d'objectif il ne s'agit plus seulement
de sortir de la crise comme on le répète
depuis des années le véritable enjeu
désormais cette entrée dans le monde
nouveau qui se construit autour de nous
bien sûr dès 2017 nous devrons engager
d'ambitieuses réformes pour redresser
notre pays que trois ans déjà cinq ans
demain de pouvoir socialiste ont plongé
dans le mas
je ne m'attendais pas sur le constat il
est connu de vous tous malgré une
conjoncture européenne et mondiale
exceptionnellement favorables du moins
pour l'instant pétrole bon marché taux
d'intérêt historiquement bas euros
proche de la parité avec le dollar
notre économie reste à la traîne le
chômage ne diminue pas les déficits
publics reste supérieur à l'objectif que
nous sommes nous mêmes fixés et dès lors
notre dette continue à s'alourdir et a
pesé sur le poids des générations qui
vont venir nous savons bien pourquoi
nous échouons nos entreprises et tous
dans un carcan fiscale et normatif qui
plombent leur compétitivité et surtout
elles ont été déboussolé par une
politique économique qui a changé de cap
tous les six mois ou presque par une
inflation désordonnée de texte brouillon
souvent rétroactif qui ont miné la
confiance qu'elle florilège de réforme
ratée une réforme territoriale qui va
alourdir la facture de notre
organisation locale et compliquer la vie
de nos concitoyens prix entre d'immenses
régions sont cohérence humaine je sais
de quoi je parle et des départements à
l'avenir incertain
et je comprends aussi le désarroi des
maires et des élus locaux qui sont
privés de moyens d'agir
une réforme des programmes du collège
écrite dans un jargon grotesque
incomprise par tous ceux qui devraient
l'appliquer et qui au nom d'un
égalitarisme stérile va tirer l'ensemble
vers le bas est une succession de
provocation à l'encontre de nos pme
qu'il s'agisse d'un conte pénibilité
ingérable ou de commissions régionales
syndicales qui viendront bientôt
interférer dans un dialogue social qui
en fait est le plus souvent harmonieux
entre les patrons de tpe et leurs
salariés
tout cela n'est ni fait ni à faire
comment dès lors s'étonner que
l'attentisme se soit installée chez tous
les acteurs de l'économie investisseurs
comme consommateurs nous auront du pain
sur la planche pour revenir dans le bon
sens et nous voyons bien ce qu'il faudra
faire restaurer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises qui attendent une puissante
cure de liberté mais aussi et surtout
l'indication d'un cap clair et stable
accroître la performance de nos
administrations nationales locales
sociale pour garantir la qualité du
service public en maîtrisant mieux la
dépense publique
réussir la mère des réformes celle de
notre système d'éducation et de
formation affermir l'état dans ses
missions régaliennes la défense
nationale la sécurité publique
la maîtrise des mouvements de population
le respect de la laïcité
sur tous ces points et quelques autres
bien sûr nous avons fait et nous ferons
les uns et les autres des propositions
précises et opérationnel en 2017
il faudra être prêts à agir mais
aujourd'hui
avec vous je voudrais porter le regard
un peu plus loin au delà du choc de
l'alternance c'est une espérance qu il
faudra faire naître on ne remet pas un
peuple en mouvement à se contentant de
lui annoncer la réforme pour la réforme
ni même nom lui promettant du sang de la
sueur et des larmes
il faut donner un sens aux réformes
une perspective de réussite et de
progrès aux efforts demandés
et pour cela il faut deux conditions
rassembler et rassembler autour d'un
projet qui suscite l'adhésion
on ne fait rien de bon dans la division
ni dans la recherche méthodique du
clivage certes parfois du conflit
peuvent naître des solutions nouvelles
mais les conflits dans notre pays
viennent tout naturellement nous sommes
grands amateurs de polémiquer
d'affrontements le rôle d'un dirigeant
n'est pas de les susciter ni de les
attiser
mais de les apaiser notre société a
besoin d'apaisement et non pas de
revanche rassemblés donc mais pour quoi
faire
le rassemblement à lui seul ne suffit
pas il faut fixer un but marqué le cap
faire partager le projet qui va
mobiliser les volontés quand le nouveau
patron d'une entreprise en difficulté
veulent à redresser il définit le projet
autour duquel il va fédérer tous les
acteurs et dirigeants les actionnaires
les salariés
il donne de la visibilité il garantit
continuité et cohérence dans les efforts
demandés et bien de même toutes
proportions gardées
pour un pays il faut montrer le cap et
je voudrais aujourd'hui proposée aux
françaises et aux français qui nous
écoutent de construire ensemble une
nation ambitieuse et heureuse dans son
siècle
pourquoi invoquer la nation pourquoi à
naples et au sentiment national parce
que dans la définition que je fais
mienne la nation m'apparaît comme le
lien de confiance que nous recherchons
comme le sentiment qui peut le mieux
dissiper nos doutes et nous remettre sur
le chemin du vivre ensemble dont nous
sommes en train de nous écarter
je perçois souvent dans l'inquiétude
formulée ou informulée qui se répand
chez compte itunes concitoyens cette
interrogation de nature existentielle
pas c'est moi le mot où allons nous que
va devenir notre pays quelle france
allons nous laisser à nos enfants
ressemblera-t-elle à celle que nous
avons reçu de nos parents et que nous
aimons nous ne reprendrons pas à ces
questions que pour ma part je comprends
faire parfaitement en parlons seulement
aux français de l'allègement des charges
fiscales et sociales qui pèsent sur les
entreprises de la simplification du code
du travail de la bonne réforme
territoriale de la remise à plat de
notre fiscalité ou du nécessaire recul
de l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans ces
réformes sont cet incontournable mais
elle ne réussiront pas si on ne donne
pas aux projets collectifs des pays
un supplément d'âme or qu'est-ce qu'une
nation
j'aime bien les idées nouvelles mais
j'avais aussi les idées qui résiste au
temps et c'est à mes yeux le cas de la
définition que renan a donné de la
nation une nation est une âme un
principe spirituel le désir de vivre
ensemble la volonté de continuer à faire
valoir l'héritage qu'on a reçu indivis
cette noble conception de la nation est
elle aujourd'hui dépassé certains se
posent la question
après tout la mondialisation un peu
abolit les frontières aussi bien
physique qui matériel elle a créé un
village global disparaissent les
différences au profit d'une culture
universelle et uniforme et je constate
qu'en réalité ce n'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe plus la globalisation avance
et plus les
hommes et les femmes du 21e siècle sont
à la recherche de la racine de l'artère
de leur communauté
je crois fort même fermement qu'il ne
faut pas opposer ces deux mouvements
l'un et l'autre très profond je crois
fermement que nous ne vivrons bien la
mondialisation et toutes les chances de
découverte des changes de compréhension
mutuelle qu'elle nous offre que si en
même temps nous avons préservé notre âme
ce qui fait ce que nous sommes c'est à
dire aussi une histoire une culture une
langue une proximité
bref tout ce que résume le sentiment
d'appartenance à la nation
c'est pourquoi je voudrais proposer aux
françaises et aux français de construire
la nation du nouveau siècle
non pas celle de la nostalgie mais celle
de l'harmonie une nation qui entreprend
qui innove qui prend des risques
la france est un pays d'entrepreneurs et
de créateurs pour la rouvrir le champ
libre
ne faudrait-il pas revisiter d'une
certaine manière le principe de
précaution est en tout cas lui adjoindre
aussi un principe d'innovation qui est
autant de valeur que le précédent une
nation capable de montrer le chemin de
la bonne croissance la croissance
compatible avec la sauvegarde de la
planète
c'est à dire sobre économe des
ressources rares fondée non pas sur le
gaspillage mais sur le recyclage
accueillante à l'économie du partage
tout entière irriguées par les
technologies numériques
une nation qui donne sa chance à chacun
de ses enfants par le renouveau de
l'éducation initiale mais aussi la
formation tout au long de la vie une
nation ouverte sur le monde
bienveillant non point par faiblesse ou
impuissance mais par choix qui
maîtrisent donc les mouvements de
population selon ce qu'elle peut
accepter plutôt que de les subir une
nation unie dans la diversité qui
respecte les différences et garantit à
chacun l'exercice de ces libertés
individuelles mais qui veille
strictement au respect du principe
républicain de laïcité
une nation qui a de l'ambition de la
fierté sans arrogance qui porte à
nouveau une vision politique pour
l'union de l'europe et utilise son
influence dans le monde pour promouvoir
la paix et le développement durable une
nation forte de ses 2 millions de
compatriotes vivant à l'étranger qui
sont les formidables ambassadeurs de
notre pays à travers la planète
une nation présente sur tous les
continents grandes puissances maritimes
grâce à nos outre-mer que nous devrions
nous y associer à notre projet collectif
bref une nation qui a confiance et qui
fait confiance aux antipodes des
nationalismes crispés ou agressif comme
de la perte des repères à quelle belle
aventure de faire de la france la nation
épanoui au tournant du 20e siècle les
amis
nous aimons souvent chanté ensemble la
marseillaise parce que l'hymne national
malgré la dureté même la violence de ces
termes nous parle de notre histoire
aux armes citoyens ce n'est évidemment
plus à l'appel belliqueux
c'est le rappel des combats qui nous ont
précédés pour conquérir la liberté dont
nous jouissons aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi il faut continuer à
prononcer ces paroles de même que nous
devons nous rassembler autour de notre
tape au pied gauche sous l'arc de
triomphe et qui est bon aussi dans la
forêt des drapeaux de l'union européenne
comme dans celle du parvis des nations
unies faire de la france une nation
d'autant plus bienveillante envers les
autres qu'elle est confiante en elle
même
ce sera lancée sur un beau projet que
nous partagerons chers amis nous vivons
ensemble une belle journée
une chaude journée maintenant nous
allons entrer dans une nouvelle campagne
après les succès que nous avons
remportés l'an dernier aux élections
municipales puis cette année aux
élections départementales
notre nouvel objectif est clairement
désigné la victoire aux élections
régionales de décembre prochain
je constate avec joie que nous sommes en
ordre autour de nos dirigeants et de nos
candidats le président que nous avons
élu il ya quelques mois a eu à coeur de
respecter les personnes et les
sensibilités de donner à chacun sa place
de faire prévaloir la volonté de
rassemblement sur toute autre
considération
je lui en sais gré
attendez il arrive il arrive c'est moi
c'est des noms mais j'allais ajouter
quelque chose de sympathique
je t'en serai gré et tu peux compter
cher nicolas dans cet esprit sur mon
soutien dans la tâche qui est la tienne
à la présidence des républicains et
maintenant mettons nous en marche ce
héros néron faisons bloc incarnons tous
ensemble l'espoir d'une alternative
heureuse pour la france
vive les républicains vive la nation
française et vive la france